Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans le Coup de Phil !
Ce matin j'ai mangé une pomme. Bon, a priori on s'en fout...
Mais moi j'me pose une question : est-ce que j'aurais pu ne pas manger cette pomme ?
Sartre m'aurait dit oui, beaucoup d'entre vous aussi... Mais je veux un avis qui me dise non !
Je veux celui du déterminisme...
... de Spinoza !
Spinoza est un philosophe qui est né à Amsterdam, qui est juif, d'origine portugaise...
...donc il a sûrement été conçu dans un club échangiste.
C'est un gros têtu qui s'est fait exclure de la communauté juive à cause de son idéologie sur Dieu
qu'il a développée notamment dans l'"Éthique", un livre qu'il a mis toute sa vie à écrire...
...et qui est sorti après sa mort. Alors qu'il a mis toute sa vie à l'écrire.
Dès le début du bouquin, il arrive et il pose ses cacahuètes en disant que Dieu et la nature, c'est la même chose !
Donc en fait : tout ce que est, est en Dieu. Et c'est la seule substance de l'Univers.
Ça bafoue complètement ce qu'on pensait de Dieu à l'époque !
Donc, tout est de cette substance qu'il appelle Dieu/la nature.
Du coup, cette substance, elle est la cause de tout, donc elle est la cause d'elle-même.
Donc elle ne peut pas ne pas être, c'est-à-dire qu'elle est nécessaire.
Et il n'y a pas de but dans l'Univers et tout ne fait que suivre l'ordre des choses et cet ordre il est déterminé !
Suivez-moi... Oh !
On est sur des terres minées !
Faites gaffe ça fait très mal quand on marche dessus...
Oui déterminé ! C'est-à-dire que tout se produit selon un enchainement nécessaire des causes et des effets,
comme dans la vidéo d'Aziatomik sur l'étrange histoire de la Why Tea Fam...
On voit plusieurs causes comme le fait d'attendre l'ascenseur,
le fait que Brice ne sache pas fermer la portière d'une voiture...
Etc, etc... qui vont entrainer un accident.
Mec, t'es sérieux de prendre ma vidéo sans prévenir ?
Ouais, j'avoue, je suis désolé... En fait j'me suis permis parce que je trouvais que c'était un bon exemple...
Ouais c'est vrai.
Dans ma vidéo un enchainement d'actions et d'évènements aboutit sur une triste conclusion.
Chaque action tire sa cause sur les actions qui ont précédé.
Donc c'est bien du déterminisme.
Mais fais gaffe mec, c'est pas pour autant que ça reste une fatalité.
Allez je te laisse, ciao mec!
Peace mec.
Alors effectivement Aziatomik a raison
Si un fataliste pense que tu mourras demain,
il dira que quoique tu fasses, que tu fasses du saut en parachute ou que tu restes chez toi,
et bien tu mourras demain si c'est écrit que tu dois mourir demain.
Comme dans "Destination Finale", où tu ne peux pas échapper au sort qui t'attend
Genre cette pauvre fille qui a son ordi qui lui tranche la gorge,
puis sa cuisine qui explose,
avec un couteau qui lui tombe dessus,
qui se fait lui-même enfoncer par une chaise.
🎵Y'a d'la joie 🎵
Alors qu'un déterministe dira que je mourrai demain
que s'il y a les causes qu'il faut pour que je meure demain,
mais je pourrai très bien ne pas mourir, ça dépend des causes.
Du coup j'aurais pas pu ne pas manger ma pomme,
parce que si je dis que j'aurais pu ne pas manger ma pomme,
ça serait admettre la possibilité que ça n'arrive pas,
alors qu'à ce moment-là y'avait toutes les causes pour que ça arrive !
Donc ça serait admettre de la contingence, c'est-à-dire l'inverse de la nécessité.
Tout est donc l'issue d'un enchaînement de causes,
même tes choix...
En gros, Spinoza réfute le libre arbitre.
Tu ne fais aucun choix, mec
M. le juge, c'est un concours de circonstances qui m'a poussé à tirer sur la gâchette...
C'est mon éducation, mes gènes, la situation...
C'est des milliers de choses à prendre en compte
Je n'ai pas choisi M. le juge,
je ne fais pas de choix...
Je suis, je suis déterminé...
D'accord, non coupable !
🎵musique de fête 🎵
Mais attention, il réfute notre libre arbitre, mais pas notre liberté.
Parce qu'en fait pour Spinoza notre liberté ne réside pas dans le fait de faire des choix.
En gros pour lui la liberté, ça ne s'oppose pas à nécessité, mais à contrainte.
Je suis libre si j'agis selon la nécessité qui vient de moi,
c'est à dire si je suis mon conatus.
Le conatus c'est l'effort de persévérance dans son être.
C'est par exemple la plante qui pousse, le cheval qui galope,
l'homme qui pense ou qui désire...
Genre t'as Schopenhauer qui l'appelait la volonté,
Freud qui l'appelait la libido...
Fin bref c'est un concept finalement, qu'on...
Qu'on connaît tus !
(rires)
En revanche je suis contraint si j'agis selon une nécessité qui est extérieure à la mienne,
comme avec les passions et les affects.
Par exemple, si je suis triste, ça va diminuer mon conatus.
Du coup notre liberté ça va être de réduire ces nécessités extérieures
et donc de comprendre nos affects et nos passions, pour moins les subir.
En gros pour schématiser : un pierre qui roule et qui tombe est libre.
Une pierre qui tombe mais qui rencontre des obstacles qui l'empêchent de rouler correctement ne l'est pas.
La pierre, c'est nous,
le fait qu'elle persévère dans son mouvement, c'est le conatus,
et les obstacles, c'est les affects et les passions.
Donc en gros on a la liberté de connaître les causes de ses actions,
mais on est pas libres quand on fait un choix.
Pourtant c'est chelou, parce que moi quand je fais un choix, j'ai vraiment l'impression d'être libre...
Et bah en fait il explique ça par une citation assez importante qu'il a sortie :
En gros pour Spinoz', vu qu'on est pas conscient de tout ce qui nous pousse à faire tel choix
et bah on pense qu'il est libre.
Regarde je vais te donner un exemple que j'aime bien :
Imagine que t'es dans une pièce et que tu dois absolument sortir
parce que par exemple, je sais pas... y'a un incendie !
Ouais...
Ouais j'fais des effets spéciaux, ouais..
Pardon...
Y'a 2 portes : la porte A et la porte B.
Donc soit je fuis en passant par la porte A, soit je fuis en passant par la porte B.
Je suis devant mes 2 portes, je choisis,
j'ai vraiment la sensation d'être libre lorsque je fais mon choix.
Je passe par la porte A... ok !
En fait il s'avère que la porte B était fermée, de toute façon.
Donc... j'aurais pas pu passer par la porte B.
De toute façon je serais passé par la porte A.
Si j'avais su que la porte B était fermée, lorsque j'avais fait mon choix,
j'aurais pas du tout eu cette sensation d'être libre.
Donc ça veut dire qu'on peut avoir la sensation d'être libre... par l'ignorance
Ouais mon gars !
Alors les mecs , petit conseil, ça tu le sors en soirée, tu pécho direct, quoi.
Testé et app...
Nan c'était que testé en fait.
Ouais, j'étais pas très en forme ce soir-là.
J'espère que le déterminisme de Spinoza est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
N'hésitez pas à checker la description pour avoir plus d'infos,
et à partager la vidéo si j'vous ai appris un truc.
En attendant j'vous envoie du love, et d'la peace...
Yalla !